[Musik]
mai zusammen schaut euch diese super
wüten leckeren mini maulwurf kuchen an
und das rezept ist gar nicht so schwer
nachzumachen
für den schoko teig benötigen wir 250
gramm butter 50 gramm speisestärke 40
gramm wasser kaum 140 gramm mehl 4 150
gramm zucker einen teelöffel vanille
extrakt und ein teelöffel backpulver
[Musik]
als erstes team ich mir meine schüssel
gebe da die mutter den zucker und auch
von den extrakt hinein und verrührt das
zirka vier bis fünf minuten lang mein
handwerk sei
danach kommen da die feier mit hinzu und
werden noch mal ordentlich untergerührt
[Musik]
wenn auch das geschafft ist mit dem wir
die trockenen brutal bleiben also
speisestärke kakao und backpulver
[Musik]
das wird nochmal kurz unter gemixt bis
alles miteinander verbunden ist und
schon ist der schoko teig fertig
derzeit kommt gibts auf mein tiefes
backblech da habe ich auch schon
backpapier draufgelegt und den
verstreichen noch einmal gab es bevor
ich ihnen am backen
nachdem dann alles schön glatt
verstrichen wurde kommt der bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen für zwölf minuten anschließend
mit einem bauboom küchentuch abdecken
und vollständig auskühlen lassen
für die füllung brauchen wir 800
milliliter schlagsahne acht teelöffel
sonderfahrt zum trinken noch einen sehr
starken trinkt kakao und vier bananen
die habe ich schon in scheiben
geschnitten
die sahne wird mit dem sommerbad
aufgeschlagen und erstmal in den
kühlschrank getan
[Musik]
jetzt gehts weiter mit dem kuchen und
dafür nehmen wir uns ein großes glas
oder einen runden ausstecher und
schneiden uns da den boden aus
[Musik]
der wird jetzt mit dem kakao gedrängt
und ich habe mir den kakao wirklich sehr
stark zubereitet damit der
schokoladengeschmack zur geltung kommt
und darauf lege ich jetzt ein paar
geschnittene bananenscheiben
[Musik]
die sahne habe ich mir mittlerweile in
meine spritzt oder umgefüllt und jetzt
spricht sich auch die banane an runde
heutigen sahne die sahne videos mit
einer winkel palette glatt gestrichen
das muss jetzt auch nicht so ordentlich
sein am ende werden also wieso die
kuchen streusel drauf verteilt
die reste der früheren werden dann mit
den händen zu sträuben verarbeitet und
die drücken wir dann auf unsere sahen
aber dass der kleine maulwurf kuchen
erhalten
[Musik]
und das war schon mit dem mini maulwurf
kuchen insgesamt bekommt die acht stück
raus oder je nachdem welche größe oder
glas oder ausstecher auch drehen und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und beim vernaschen
ich würde mich selbstverständlich über
einen daumen hoch freuen und auch wenn
ihr mich abonniert oder das video sogar
bis zum nächsten mal auf die tiefs
kitchen